[Music]
in this episode of street talk unplugged
today we are speaking with dr thomas lux
a research scientist at meta in silicon
valley
don't forget to join our amazing discord
community we just had our first event on
wednesday on discrete program synthesis
and we've got plenty more things lined
up uh as always if you like content like
this consider hitting the like and
subscribe button and also rating our
podcast on apple podcast because it
really helps us out
now um in some sense
all of supervised machine learning can
be framed through the lens of geometry
all training data exists as points in a
euclidean space and we want to predict
the value of a function at all of those
points
neural networks appear to be the modus
operandi these days for many domains of
prediction and in that light we might
want to ask ourselves
what makes neural networks better than
classical techniques like nearest
neighbor from a geometric perspective
our guest today has done research on
exactly that problem
trying to define error bounds for
approximations
in terms of directions
distances
and derivatives
now the insights from thomas's work
point at why neural networks are so good
at problems which everything else fails
at like image recognition for example
the key according to thomas is their
ability to ignore parts of the input
space to do non-linear dimension
reduction and concentrate their
approximation power on important parts
of the function
this geometric perspective shows that
many different neural network
architectures are equivalent to data
augmentation yet the standard mlp the
multi-layer perceptron still underpins
everything at the back end
all of the inductive price of neural
networks are essentially data
replicators to enable an interpolation
regime for a particular invariance of
what would have been extrapolation
now they do this by replicating lots of
copies of data into the ambient space so
that the mlps on the end can act as a
locality sensitive hashing table
take self attention for example right
transformers they just permute two
tuples of your set data which is to say
generating all of the possible pairs in
every single layer this in effect
marginalizes over the domain of that
particular invariance which turns out to
be very powerful in discrete token
prediction problems like natural
language processing interestingly though
thomas thinks that the secret is in the
aggregation rather than the permutation
of the values
anyway on that i recommend you check out
fabian fuchs review article on learning
on sets fabian has some ridiculously
deep insights on how these models work
and geometric deep learning in in
general and guess what we're going to be
having a deep dive discussion with
fabian in the next few weeks so i'm so
excited about getting him on the show
now
in this show thomas lux explained that
the main reason mlps outperform simple
space partitioning algorithms is that
they work in high dimensions and that
they can or at least to some degree
disentangle data density and information
density having lots of data sampled in a
region of the function space doesn't
necessarily mean that it's salient right
that it's a salient place to learn from
in neural networks the partitioning of
the space is driven by error and it's
weighted by the number of samples so the
neural networks are not able to
completely disentangle this signal now
neural networks also support creating a
non-regular input specific lattice to
decompose the input space which is
something that other geometric methods
like the lornoid triangularization that
simply can't do
now after our episode of lacuna and
ballistriero we had a few comments
saying that the spline conception of
mlps was only relevant to relu
activation functions well today let's
just say we're going to dispatch with
that notion rather quickly
so now i give you
dr thomas lux okay so we are here with
dr thomas lux from meta ai research over
in silicon valley uh thomas introduce
yourself
yeah hi so yeah you got it i'm thomas
i've been with meta since uh april of
last year
and well largely we connected because of
my hobby research but i've got a phd in
computer science my background's in
numerical analysis technically which is
the study of how error grows as you
compound computations but i have a deep
interest in ai and it's
uh its roots in geometry and directions
distances and derivatives and trying to
come up with new techniques
and push towards you know better
artificial intelligence algorithms more
robustness
more consistent behavior everything
amazing well when we first met thomas
you sent me your paper which was all
about um comparing different
interpolation methods with mlps
and
it was really interesting for me because
you know recently we had that
conversation with randall balestrio and
we learned all about this spline theory
of neural networks and that is very much
about carving the ambient space up into
these polyhedrons
and all of a sudden i guess the reason
it was such an insight for me was i
could suddenly think of mlps the same
way as i've thought of traditional
machine learning algorithms i've always
thought of them as
you know in in a variety of slightly
different ways kind of um chopping up
the input space either by having an
epsilon around the training data or as
decision trees do you know kind of
carving them up with these discrete
rules and now suddenly i saw neural
networks in in the same way but actually
in that paper you were very much seeing
um all of the machine learning
algorithms in that way so can can you
give us a bit of an intro into that
paper in your thinking
i originally started doing approximation
style problems which is like all of
machine learning supervised machine
learning uh in grad school but only
using techniques that are like strictly
founded on geometry so the most basic
and obvious examples is nearest neighbor
um so the idea right is you have some
input space and you have some output
space you're trying to approximate
the the way uh the first time i showed
nero you know my
neural network architecture that i'd
used in my paper to my advisor he he's
not into neural networks he's only into
a lot of older mathematical stuff and he
was like oh it's just a piecewise linear
approximation it was funny it was early
in grad school i was like oh
actually yeah with real activation it's
just a giant piecewise linear function
um yeah so as soon as i knew it was a
giant piecewise linear function in my
mind what it connected back to was the
delaney triangulation and uh dulani
triangulation it's got a lot of
interesting properties i actually worked
on a code with my lab mate uh that we
published in grad school on that uh it's
a and it's a great approximation
technique because it's the
generalization of linear interpolation
to any dimension um so i mean it's super
consistent right it's determined uh it
has some properties that are that we can
prove which is really nice and that was
like the emphasis of my phd is trying to
come up with these provable properties
of you know error bounds how do you how
do you stop your approximation from
getting worse
then i uh
you know now with delaney and the neural
network both being piecewise linear and
turbulence i was like okay so that's my
connection is like you know everything a
neural network does is goal is to break
up the space into little well in this
case it's polytopes because it's not
always simplicities like a deulani
triangulation uses but yeah and fit
those those shapes to whatever your
underlying surfaces
but amazing i mean for our audience
could you introduce some of these
concepts so we spoke of simplices and
delano triangulation and varroanoy as
well so i mean these are all ways of you
know kind of partitioning the euclidean
space but could you give a bit of flavor
on that
yeah so like
let's see the best place to start i
think is with pictures because
everything is intuitive when you can
draw pictures of it and even when i'm
trying to understand neural networks and
stuff i go in and draw pictures of it um
and i can i have some visuals of like
the actual regions that a neural network
breaks a simple function up into so you
can see it but the the premise of a
dilani triangulation is like start with
a 1d picture and you know draw lines
between points and that's your
interpolant that's the function you're
going to guess if you just have a 1d
function
now once you go to two dimensions how do
you draw the lines between the points
because
the it's no longer obvious which
direction to draw the line and so it
turns out if you make the only property
the only required property that if you
uh
they're in two dimensions exactly three
points uh define a circle right so if
you uh
look at the circle that intercepts any
set of three points you could call it uh
a nearby like a a closed a nice simplex
if the thr the three points that hit the
edges of that circle are the only points
that touch that circle and no others are
inside of it and there's actually a
really good visual that's just on the
wikipedia page for delany that i'm sure
you can show here but it's uh that
single property results in this uh these
collections of points and so it's always
going to be if you have d dimensions in
your input it's always going to be d
plus one points and that will form the
the generalization of a triangle and
that is what defines a plane so if you
think about it a linear function in any
dimension is defined exactly by d plus
one points and so when you break up all
of your data you take your input space
and you group them in this way where
they what they call that as the circum
ball is empty the the ball that
intercepts any the the points of the
vertices of a simplexes only has those
points on it uh then you form a unique
uh piecewise linear interplay of your
data and unique is really good right
because we want to prove things you need
to to say with confidence that this is
the only outcome and if you once you
have a delaney mesh you can start to
actually prove properties of the error
which is what led me down that whole
paper track that you read
fascinating so just to reiterate things
i i really want to articulate this as
clearly as possible the magic of machine
learning is that we have a bunch of
training data in euclidean space and via
a variety of techniques we can create
some kind of enclosure
and then inside that enclosure we can
interpolate and that that forms some
kind of approximation bound you know for
us to generalize to new testament and
now of course we'll get on to the curse
of dimensionality in in a minute yeah
but the basis of your paper was you you
experimented with a whole bunch of these
highly principled ways of partitioning
the input space around the training
examples and performing interpolation
within those let's call them polytopes
but maybe that's not the right um and
and they compared rather favorably to
mlps
yeah so that was what i think was
of most interest to my advisor and a lot
of times that's how grad school goes
uh but it also of interest to me is
all of the everything machine learning
like you're saying you could think of it
as partitioning space or really i like
to always break it back down to just
you've got a one-dimensional function
and you're drawing a line through it
right you're interpolating your data or
you're regressing your data you're doing
one or the other and all of this is just
how can we generalize that exact same
concept uh into more data higher
dimensions more data points
um
so the the interesting result for my
advisor was these are the methods that
he had worked on his whole career so he
liked seeing them compared with what's
really common right now which is the
neural networks but also if we prove
something is the case like we prove that
delany is good then we want to see it we
want to see those results in action we
know that delawny converges on the true
underlying function as long as it's uh
deterministic or it's not sarcastic it
has exact values
uh and so
the idea is all these problems that
we're selling machine learning
presumably if we're getting good
accuracy we're converging on the
underlying function so delaney should
perform well and that was the motivation
for the whole paper is we lay down
delaney
linear shepard so shepard and variants
are just inverse distance waiting
functions so like imagine nearest
neighbor but instead of doing just the
nearest point you do a weighted
combination of all your data and you
determine the weights with the distance
to the data point um so yeah compared
all of these with some
like regression techniques from the 90s
that are good like multivariate adaptive
regression splines um which is also a
very neat space partitioning algorithm
uh and yeah and what came out was yeah
sure enough these other techniques also
work really well
it's not just neural networks that work
really well but neural networks do excel
in a case that is very challenging for
all the classical techniques and that's
when you have high dimension and when
the surface you're trying to approximate
so if you think about your data it lives
on some manifold somewhere in your input
space uh when that surface is a is not
is a non-linear subsurface so like you
can't just take the principal components
and get your function what if what if
the function is really important in this
part of the space and really important
in this part of the space but then
everything in between isn't important
the neural networks the magic that they
have that nothing else has is uh being
being able to do non-linear dimension
reduction so they can reduce the
dimension of your whole input space and
simultaneously capture the fact that
there are disparate s sets in the space
that are important
i don't think it's necessary to bring in
non-linearity at this point like we're
just talking about piecewise linearity
right
and so and so i i think the point here
is that
i'm assuming that you tell me when you
laid down a delaney triangle let's just
pretend it's a 2d plane okay i'm just
trying to interpolate a two-dimensional
function
i'm assuming you just laid down some
regular
delaney triangulation like like the
equivalent of just a typical triangular
mesh or something right because you uh
you know
the hard part is choosing the points of
the triangles
it doesn't have to be a regular mesh i
could have a big triangle over here a
bunch of small ones over there
and unless you've you know come up with
something like you just said the only
thing that the thing that neural
networks can do
which no other method up until at least
max affine splines which you know we had
this review this paper recently can do
is they can divide up that space
adaptively you know they can decide look
i need lots more triangles over in this
region i don't need a bunch of triangles
over here there's no there's nothing
here beyond just piecewise linearity
it's just it can choose to refine
regions of the space
adaptively so that's what we're talking
about right uh yeah but so i think like
if we think about it every time we want
to talk about how good something is uh
we need to make assumptions about the
input and so if you have this 2d plane
that we've drawn right and you've got a
lot of points in one place and not a lot
of points in another place um
where you have high density of data
isn't necessarily where the underlying
function is changing the most so if you
want to talk about like if you're
thinking about just drawing a piecewise
linear interpolant over a surface uh
what you do is you you want data where
the function surface changes the most
because that way uh every time the
function changes a linear interpolant
gets worse right well that's really and
i want to put an anchor down on that
yeah so yeah you're saying where there's
loads of density of data the func that
that might not be you know region of
information
do neural networks for example um
do they suffer from that so if you give
them lots of data in a region of the
ambient space
will they place because of the three i
want to frame this up a little bit
because i think where we're getting to
here is neural networks are
parameterized models
and what they do essentially is is they
place all of these basis functions in
the ambient space
and
where those functions are placed is of
interest to us
so let's start with the assumption that
do they get placed more densely where
there's more data density rather than
information density so that is the
beauty of following the gradient um
they place basis functions where error
is high that's where the basis functions
will cluster to where the error is high
if you have a lot of data in one region
and no change perfectly linear flat
function the as soon as one basis
function hits that data it'll go the
gradient goes to zero so the neural
network goes oh well i don't need more
information there so it does do a good
job of adaptively saying i only need
information where the where the
underlying function is changing a lot
and this is where classical techniques
and neural net neural networks diverge
you know i'm working on this theory i
want to have a good robust theory for
neural networks um but the where they
diverge is the classical techniques
largely assume the your input space is
nice so like you know your data is
spaced according to the function they
assume that directions are all equally
important like you know yeah and that's
not the case when we're doing image
classification not all directions are
equally important in pixel space you
know pixel space is a very weird
phenomenon um and we don't really have
any theory that covers the idea of this
i call it like a uh sampled subsurface
functions so if you think about uh image
recognition it's not uh it's not a
the function that you're defining isn't
in a million dimensions right we live in
a three-dimensional reality with time
fourth dimension so
where are we getting a million
dimensions from million dimensions are
exponentially larger than three and it's
because we have the sampling phenomenon
right we sample our single underlying
function in lots of places
where in approximation theory do we do
we have uh error bounds for functions
that approximate this sampling
phenomenon and that's kind of the
direction i'm trying to go with my
personal research this is not affiliated
with meadow but it's something i'm very
interested in um and it's uh
yeah and this this is the thing that
neural networks are really good at and
this is you know that was like my
primary takeaway from doing that deep
dive comparison between classical
techniques and neural networks
fascinating
so when we spoke last time thomas you
were saying and that you discovered
something really interesting around the
placement
of these basis functions in in the
ambient space it always occurred to me
my intuition was and i think i said this
on the lacoon show and i realized i was
wrong after speaking with you is that i
i assume that the basis functions would
be placed in the vicinity of the
training data
but that's not the case is it you you've
you've got some preliminary research
that they they're randomly initialized
of course and they don't really move
very much the only thing that changes is
their pose yeah yeah so and this is like
you know this is the great question and
all through grad school before i was uh
more invested into research for neural
networks i was like
solving a non-convex optimization
problem over your data to do regression
when you have all this other stuff that
seems silly like why are people using
neural networks to do all these problems
when you i mean think about the wasted
resources of resolving a regression
problem from scratch when you know with
classical techniques you have
immediately updated models every time
you have new data you have a lot of
benefits that come from that um
and
though you know what i realized though
initialization matters but we don't have
good deterministic answers for what
initialization is good when and why um
and so
you know the first question you might
ask is like
you know during training if you're
trying to prove something what about my
network or model architecture can
totally prevent me from converging or
actually what even just does happen and
so i went in and i recorded how do all
the shift terms change for all the
linear basis functions how do their
directions change how their magnitudes
change and yeah what i found was really
interesting if you look at this the the
shift terms
for the most part don't move at all and
what that tells you is like in this
giant non-convex optimization space that
we're solving for a neural network uh
a lot of learning can be done with
directions but a lot of weight is coming
from this arbitrary initial choice of
shift terms and why is that and
certainly there's some great theory
that's underneath this that we could dig
into um and that's kind of like that was
my motivating initial experiment is
seeing what does and doesn't move um and
now after i don't know if you've seen
the paper that's blown up recently about
a forward grading or forward
differentiation and not needing the full
back propagation for the gradients so
this has been all over twitter as of
like friday and it's interesting can you
fill us in on that and also i'm really
keen to know your theory on as you said
let's say you've got poses and shifts
is it because one seems to dominate the
other in the optimization objective so
is it
is it just a symptom of we haven't tuned
to this thing correctly or do you think
it's more fundamental than that
the real thing is it's a hard problem to
solve it's not an easy like we've we've
created a difficult optimization problem
and when when your space grows right and
you're trying to optimize any function
just classic optimization if you if it's
not a convex function so you can't
guarantee that downhill gets you the
global solution there's no other answer
than to search everywhere
that's you
there's no magic there's no way to say
oh i actually know i need to go this
different direction only thing you can
do is follow the gradient you can make
some guesses so
what that tells us is we need more we
need a little bit more information we
need to look at the way the neural
networks are structured and see if we
can glean a little bit more than just oh
it's a non-convex space well if i can if
i can maybe more directly you know
answer answer your question tim i mean
it could be something as simple as the
fact that
if you change the you know the direction
of a hyperplane
that's going to impact every single
thing that you've calculated for all
data points that are on on the side of
that hyperplane whereas if you shift if
you shift its position a little bit
you're only gonna you're only gonna chop
off some some data points or some other
ones but you're not gonna have as much
of a directional effect it's just like
the further away if you've got an arm
and you're rotating it on a circle you
know the further away the radius is from
that that point right you're going to
have a massive massive change in the
value what you're getting at is
curvature is the loss function has a lot
higher curvature with twist right
because if you have a point that's
really far away down out on the end of
the arm of the basis function and you
turn it you move that point a lot which
changes everything about it downstream
whereas when you shift and you don't
move you move all points the same amount
which uh is lower curvature
just to throw another curveball into the
mix as well so neural networks have this
really interesting property of
entanglement so all of these basis
functions they are um kind of like a
combination of all of the topologically
addressable neurons a honeycomb of
honeycombs yeah yeah so this
optimization problem it's it's not just
the the individual um neuron it's
actually all of the addressable neurons
so doesn't that make it even more
complex well yeah and i think the
the i always like to go back to the
simplest visual i can make the simplest
answer is linear regression um when you
have linear regression your answer isn't
just a function of the weight on one of
your inputs
the the optimal solution is a function
of all of the weights on all of the
other inputs and so actually there is
there's a conditional dependence on uh
one direction being picked and another
direction being picked because uh it
might be the case like the simple
explanations there might be a case where
if you only have one option you would
pick one input number one if you had two
options though you would pick inputs two
and three not one because two and three
recreate one it's like there's this
conditional dependence that gets created
once you have more options once you have
more neurons more dimensions um so yeah
that again that makes it a hard problem
fascinating for me extrapolation is
about this notion of continuing the
pattern so imagine we had a spiral
manifold and i want to be able to um
uh predict inside the spiral manifold
outside of the training range that's
what i mean by that's a fun data set
because that that always breaks
breaks
it's beautiful right but um
if i was doing symbolic regression i
would absolutely be able to do that and
i think when people talk about
extrapolation that's what they mean so
when we talk with symbolists and they
talk about being able to perform
abstract extrapolation
what they mean is being able to use a
little bit of knowledge and semantics
and and kind of cast it into a
completely different situation now
we know based on the conversation that
we've just been having that the basis of
machine learning models are interpretive
we're just kind of moving around in
these little kind of
enclosures in the euclidean space
so
i have this very loose intuition i'd
love to test it on you thomas that the
way that we make these models
extrapolate
you know with these inductive priors is
almost by kind of um replicating the
information into lots of different areas
of the ambient space so that these
interpretative methods work now remember
francois relay said we've got to make
the methods interpolative well let's
let's test the principle for a cnn so a
cnn has this translational weight
sharing and you have the tennis ball and
you're now shining the filter over the
input space and you're producing a
response map so what that's essentially
doing is it's making copies of that
pattern and kind of scattering it over
the ambient space well it's not the
ambient space it's the response map
space and then i'm doing an mlp on the
end and and that's how i'm kind of
extrapolating by cheating so yes it's
outside of the distribution of the
original data but i've kind of cheated
by projecting it using this cnn
well i don't know that i'd call it
cheating um because almost in line what
uh
you know i think it was francis delay
said is
you want to interpolate i mean the i
yeah but i think the cheating part is
that that the you know the convolution
part of cnns is not machine learned
a human being encodes the convolution
right and so that's that's what we mean
by cheating is the human being
structuring in these um so this is a
deep area of interest for me because i'm
you know i'm trying to come up with any
theory and what bothers me the most is
transformers like transformers they're
solving this problem what are they doing
that so well and right now my best guess
is is actually there's there is still a
much simpler architecture that might
work it's not totally i haven't
formalized it perfectly yet but it comes
down to solving this problem of a
positional inputs inputs that the
ordering doesn't matter or how many of
them you have doesn't really matter uh
because you're and this is the same for
the image for vision right you're
sampling an underlying surface if i yank
out a few of the pixels it shouldn't
matter shouldn't change anything um it's
really the the sum of all the samples in
the image so the sum is doesn't have
ordering and so i think that's what
really transformers are getting at is
this the ability to process a positional
functions or inputs that are coming from
functions that don't have an implicit
ordering and if you remove the implicit
ordering you can get back to
interpolation you don't have to worry
about extrapolation
that's fascinating i'd love to meditate
on this a little bit longer so
there are different ways of
understanding transformers as i've heard
articulated by many of my friends and i
think one way which is similar to what
you're saying is that they're a kind of
generalization of deep sets
um but they're permutation invariant so
like
one one way of visualizing how they work
is think of thinking of them as a graph
learning algorithm
um where you're just learning um
relationships between all of the tokens
another way i've heard of explaining
them is thinking that of them as an
information retrieval system with the
keys and the queries but if d do you
have a really simple kind of intuition
around how you think they work so i
guess i do want to clarify one thing
relu activation
uh weight matrices linear functions this
is still a piecewise linear function all
we've done is do we've done we've done
some feature engineering inside of it
and we've we've structured our piecewise
linear function to match our assumed
structure of the data which is that uh
the people what they're capturing with
transformers is attention right
attention is
combinations of things matter
combinations matter more than order
combination combinations can come in
weird ways like sometimes but sometimes
the patterns you want to pick up are
based on combinations of elements
values at specific positions
that's and that's all again that's we've
engineered that feature just like uh
keith was saying right we've we've human
learned
that this architecture works well um and
so the way i think of transformers is
the most i think i think the most
important part of them is out is the
fact that they have an a positional
operator an out of order operator
doesn't matter what order things go in
it creates an approximation and why is
that relevant because a lot of our
problems are like that people will still
understand sentences if you rearrange
the words they'll still recognize words
if you rearrange the letters it is the
the context of what is in there at the
same time that matters more than the
specific order that it's in
yeah but let's let's be really careful
because uh if i you know if i say um
you know bill kicked john and i swapped
the positions of you know bill and john
i wind up with the opposite conclusion
so i may think we're taking this a bit
too far like uh even in images you said
order doesn't matter that's obviously
wrong right like the this the 2d spatial
representation or spatial relations
between the data
you know matter a lot i agree you can
take out some pixels but that's because
you you have you have the idea that
there's a world model which says
underneath that is some larger scale
feature and and i'm doing some kind of
like sub sampling of it so i think
it's just the transformers add in the
capability to ignore order like a lot of
what you know tim a lot of what we've
kind of discovered in the past here is
that
these invariants that that people encode
one way in which you know they try to do
them if they can't figure out how to
actually encode it in the structure of a
neural network is through data
augmentation and when you go to do data
augmentation what you do is you do tons
and tons of transforms to your data you
do all the transforms that you want the
neural network to learn to ignore
so for example if you want to learn to
ignore order you put in all the inputs
in every conceivable order if you want
to learn to ignore rotation to learn
rotational variance you rotate all your
images by increments of five degrees so
interestingly enough what i was going to
say is that a lot of the invariant
structure is about teaching or a lot of
what we're trying to get neural networks
to learn how to do is to ignore certain
aspects of the data and from my
perspective that's exactly analogous or
even equivalent to abstraction
abstraction is all about ignoring
elements of the of the data that that's
right but it's also i think testing the
principle analogous to margin
marginalization and in bayesian models
so what you're doing in a cnn is you're
basically saying i'm i'm as you're
saying i'm i'm going to go over the
entire domain of this thing by shining
it everywhere so that you can learn it
in all places in a transformer it's it's
learning um
k tuples right so so you've got
permutation uh invariants for sets of
two right so all of the combinations so
what you're doing in that quadratic
transformer layer is you're saying okay
i'm going to try all of the combinations
that's
it seems computationally exhaustive to
do that
well
so
you know
finding the global optimum is is
computationally exhaustive
all the time and so what we're doing is
these differentiable tricks so whatever
you know
if if a transformer is trying to learn
these possible permutations it's only
doing so by way of some some
differentiable
kind of trick right like um
it's all about trying to find ways in
which to
have a smooth learnable function that
approximates some kind of more
discrete you know sort of symbolic thing
like like the point that thomas brought
up earlier about
you know i should be able to take an
image and throw out pixels it's not that
i'm
you know in a technical sense the
ordering
you know hasn't changed right because
you still have like pixel whatever pixel
is to the left of one is still to the
left of one but the sequencing change
there's no longer like stuff
stuff in between them and
it should be able to learn that and
that's about trying to learn these
longer range connections that ignore
you know some some stuff in between
and so could you come up with a smooth
differentiable way
to say for example toss out
every third pixel sure you could
actually do that by
by uh weighting every third pixel by
some alpha and then explore what happens
when it goes to zero right and then you
might be able to and you can imagine
doing that for kind of every every sort
of frequency and maybe come up with some
cool basis functions that can smoothly
transition between ignoring combinations
of pixels
my pet peeve with the uh with data
augmentation is that if we're really
going to progress towards ai then
the internal functions created inside
the model for whatever problems are
solved like
the my analogy is i'm a person if i
think something enough times it almost
becomes like a little program and that a
part of my brain
becomes designated at autocompleting
that program and so i can like i can
create programs um if if we want a model
to be able you can synthesize programs
program synthesis so
but if if we're going to have a model
that can do that we can't have this
prerequisite that we know the structure
of the function we're approximating and
that we can hand craft architecture so i
think you're right like the problem is
there's a mixture of positional and a
positional information in these
functions and so if we're gonna have one
general architecture that approximates
things that we don't have to handcraft i
feel like it's going to be exactly that
it's going to have an a positional front
end that aggregates things and encodes
them in some embedded space and then
it's going to have an mlp on the back
and the mlp does all your positional
processing and i really i think we'll
get there well just uh just a small
quibble there like i'm always leery when
i hear about assuming a front end or
because that that's assuming a kind of
implicit order like that i do
you know a positional first and then
positional i think in some distant
future we're going to figure out some
way to like smoothly hybridize
you know those approaches and even have
multi-layer
kind of
cyclic evaluation i try to simplify as
much as possible and you the problem is
you can't
you can't put the positional first
because if you have an eight positional
information you have to do data
augmentation right you have to do all
the rotating in order to make the
positional function learn correctly if
you put the a positional model first
then as long as the embedding that it's
producing is big enough it could
perfectly reproduce your input data
which means you keep all your
information for the positional model so
actually i think it has to be in that
order you do a positional first then you
do a positional and that should be then
i know i'm using this phrase as weird i
mean like you know
unordered set processing first and then
uh regular mlp which is each input
component has a specific meaning second
so thomas do you agree though with this
idea that
i'm i'm fascinated by discrete program
induction by the way and and the the the
potential for um uh you know for
for what we can represent with discrete
programs going forwards but um my
intuition is that um all continuous
machine learning
um
it all happens in this euclidean space
and the only way we can achieve the
parlor trip the parlor trick of
extrapolation is by littering the
euclidean space with what i see as space
junk
so you know we've got loads of junk
floating around the earth at the moment
all of these inductive priors what they
seem to be doing is just taking load
data augmentation it's it's all the same
thing it's creating loads and loads of
space junk
so that we can have the parlor trick of
extrapolation and generalization i mean
do you agree with that premise
yeah yeah i mean the
i don't know if i call it a partner
trick like again like littering the
space like that is actually turning our
extrapolation problem into an
interpolation problem and so let's be
clear
if exactly if you want to extrapolate
you have to know something about your
function like you you have to know some
underlying structure to do
human level symbolic
extrapolation we make the assumption
that we have the correct symbolic
representation and then we extrapolate
that
but that's an assumption
well that
that's that's a really interesting way
that's a better way to frame it i should
have framed it like that so for
continuous machine learning models to
work we have to gentlemen charles said
as well we have to um represent
extrapolation as interpolation which
means we need to transform it into an
interpretative space um it
why not just come up with an
extrapolative model in the first place
so
i think it's like i always take it back
to the simple example say i have a
picture i give you two points you draw a
line between them and say okay cool and
i ask you what happens outside of that
how do you have any way of guessing
well without any domain knowledge you
have no way of guessing so yes
extrapolation is hard if we have two
points i can draw a line between them
and i can say actually that's probably a
pretty good guess you know if it's a
continuous function yeah the idea if if
we go out
i don't know i don't have any guarantees
anymore i mean i'd probably just extend
that line but that's all i can guess you
know that's all i can give you but if
this is the representational substrate
for the kind of information we have in
in these models do you think it's a good
substrate for
i mean you know like a lot of go-fi
people talk about um onto logical
information and discreet ways of
representing knowledge and so on do you
think that
it's appropriate to store that kind of
information in a vector space okay i
don't often
refer to the brain because i feel like
usually people start referring to the
brain in biology and evolution when they
don't understand the problem which is
okay because we use analogies to
understand things but this is a case
where i think referring to the brain is
good um
we know that a discrete logic space like
a symbolic logic space uh the functions
you can represent there is going to be a
subset of what you can represent with a
continuous space
uh the real number line is uncountably
infinite the integer number line is
countably infinite it's smaller
um
but we still use language we still use
words we still we still collapse to
these categorical symbols and
representations and i think this is the
thing that everyone's trying to capture
i don't think
that's an accident i feel like it you
know the most it happened because it was
the most likely outcome because it was
the easiest thing to do to achieve the
goals that brought us here today and so
i think there is an important collapse
to categories but i think you do it in
your real space you're still living in a
real space but sometimes it's just
convenient for information storage for
compression and then when it comes to
language for uh communication like how
can you how do we communicate thoughts
every one of us has a different thought
embedding for a specific thing
we have no way of sharing that embedding
from inside our neurons to someone
else's brain so we forcibly we had to
come up with these categories that we
agreed roughly represent the same
thought embeddings inside each other's
heads just because just because
let's let's say some wave form some
function whatever um
is actually smooth
doesn't mean that it isn't
so curved and certain in certain parts
of it that any practical utility of that
curvature is is just not relevant so for
example in the case of neurons in your
brain you know yes if you stuck an
electrode on the on the axon of a
of a neuron and measured it um you would
find at least all the way down to the
the degree of an electron volt or you
know however much energy is in a single
electron that it's the smooth
you know and continuous function
although it's going to be highly highly
highly peaked right it's going to have
this pulse
okay
and so the problem is that
that in
the sort of smooth um let's say computer
forms of neural networks that we have
today like differentiable turing
machines and
neural turing machines and things like
that
the more and more they become more
discreet the more and more in which they
become you know kind of peaked with the
very high curvature sorts of functions
the less and less they're trainable
right so it almost
doesn't matter you know whether you're
talking about the extreme of a discrete
you know function or a nice smooth
slowly changing smooth function
if you become more and more like the
other you inherit all the pros and all
the cons
of whichever extreme you know whichever
pole you're kind of approaching there so
i think it's a bit of a of a like an
attempt to escape the fact that it
doesn't matter if you if you still
maintain continuous functions but yet
you make them so curved that they
function as if they were discrete
functions you're not going to evade the
problems that we already have just in
the kind of simpler more abstract
discrete world i guess maybe this is a
good connection like i don't see a
reason that relu like just the rectified
linear or any piecewise linear you could
have picked anything uh
relu just empirically looks like it has
the most promise so let's build theory
around that um you can get everywhere
with that i don't think i think
introducing other functions is just it's
it's more complexity and it might work
for some problems it's not gonna work
for others uh i think generally we start
with occam's razors yeah yeah i agree
with you there and
more profound for me after after this
this talk with uh ballisterio and and uh
lacoon is that i used to in my mind
think you know because because i started
off with neural networks like old school
when they were sigmoids and so they were
nice and smooth and in my imagination
okay in my imagination i always thought
that neural networks were taking huge
advantage of that little smooth elbow to
do cool things like if like if there was
a parabola it's going to put a smooth
elbow like right
on the top of the parabola to match that
you know curvature or whatnot in the and
we've been asked this multiple times in
the youtube comments but it's like lol
if you just use a smooth function it
destroys your argument they're totally
missing the point which is
those little smooth parts of the
activation functions i think in the
current paradigm of neural networks are
basically just thrown out they're
ignored it's not even it's not even
using that smooth section to any
significant degree what it's doing
is exactly what it does with rel use
which is chop up the space into this
honeycomb of honeycombs and effectively
take advantage of the linear parts of
the activation functions to do these
linear interpolations which is why all
these piecewise linear techniques
continue to dominate become even more
dominant people find when they increase
linearity by putting in linearizing
constraints and things like that
better performance it's all because the
smooth the smooth curvature gets in the
way actually the mathematically
principled way to say that is
uh i think is you're looking at the
conditioning of your function and the
conditioning is essentially going to be
a function of the the difference between
the steepest and the least deep part
kind of in part that sounds bad for relu
but really what it means is when you
apply a relu and it actually and it hits
the layer part this is the vanishing
gradient problem right you make your
learning problem harder if uh if your
function your basis functions have high
curvature curvature is any nonzero uh
there's right any non-zero second
derivative yeah they have any non-zero
second derivative you're increasing
curvature and that curvature is going to
be magnified multiplied into the lost
landscape which means you're going to
have an even harder non-conduct
optimization problem to solve so if
they're all going to get you to the same
place in the end i would pick the one
that's an easier optimization problem to
solve which is a function that's
conditioned really nicely because it uh
what's the easy way to say this is
imagine when you have a linear function
and you point it a little differently
the whole space shifts linearly right
everything is linearly moved now when
you have a non-linear function you point
it pointed a little bit the whole space
shifts non-linearly and that means that
all your loss function has shifted
non-linearly uh
yeah right is that why
i remember was it andre capati or
when when release first came out it was
um
kind of conventional wisdom that your
model would converge about six times
faster
and is is that is that your intuition
yeah yeah like so really anything we do
to train a neural network faster comes
down to
how did we make the lost landscape nicer
that's one way to view it we either made
the lost landscape nicer so more convex
or more of the lost landscape points to
a single global minimum or we have a
better estimate of the function so it's
like atom versus sgd atom is almost a
second order method right it's creating
an approximation for the curvature of
your function and so
this is all this all comes back to
really basic examples right if you have
a quadratic function a perfect one and
you minimize it then having a quadratic
approximation will get you there fastest
you know and so it's like uh the the
nicer we can make the function and the
nicer we can make our approximation
those are the only two ways we
accelerate convergence everywhere for
all problems otherwise it's heuristics
otherwise we've done something for a
specific problem that works there but it
won't work anywhere else obviously
leaving aside a couple small
technicalities here which is that sure
if you have an activation function
that's using some expensive
transcendental you know function calls
you know but and you're not accounting
for that so in other words if the
training time isn't in terms of sort of
numbers of evaluations of the function
versus how many cpu cycles you know then
you can kind of get into issues and
mislead yourself and then and let us not
confuse our listeners relu is a
non-linear function it is a piecewise
linear function however and it's
important to understand that you know it
is
what's funny is like you were kind of
saying the more curvature you have um
the uh
the harder the optimization problem gets
unless you have a point of infinite
curvature and then it's okay because we
develop you know algorithms to deal with
that so like in the case of relu it's
got this nice linear piece where it can
do all kinds of cool stuff and it just
so happens that if the data is on the
other side of the
the function i.e the flat side it just
ignores it i mean it's you know just
takes it out of the um
that particular branch if you will the
optimization but the problem is when you
when you evade that by having a little
bit of
smooth non-linearity there that can
spread out then it makes sure it makes
your optimization problem harder
very cool well thomas what's top of mind
for you at the moment you know my
personal track is trying to
you know figure out anything that i can
prove right look what can i prove about
a neural network how can we how can we
get to a place where these are more
deterministically inconsistently
trainable um
where they can solve the same network
same architecture can solve more
problems and solve them with bounds
people care a lot about explainability
so when you can prove things you can
usually explain them a little better
and right now my track is it's kind of
an interesting one it relates to what i
mentioned earlier which is this
people are seeing i think it's the
forward derivative
they're saying you don't need to use
back prop to train your network you can
train your network without back
propagation you only have to do it layer
wise you can do it faster
and this actually closely relates to the
line of research that i'm most
interested in right now which is
initialize your network right whatever
network you want push your data through
it
record the representations of the data
your embeddings at every single node in
your network uh there are a few
properties that that should there should
be things that hold true
uh if you look at the very input of the
data
when you would when you reduce it right
when you push it to the network its
principal components are going to change
so that means if it only has one or two
dimensions of variance that will change
the network we would hope it actually
increases but never uh fatally decreases
right if the principal components go to
zero you squash your daddy of nothing so
that's one property the other is
uh
somehow your data should morph to look
more like your output as it goes through
the network so at the very last layer
the similarity between your
representations and your final output
should be very high and one way of
thinking about that is
neural network you can think of the
whole thing up to the last layer as a
learned basis approximator which is it's
trying to learn a set of basis functions
such that at your last layer you have a
set of good basis functions over your
data for representing your final output
and so if we look at this in this
context where we're trying to construct
good basis functions at the output then
we can
construct error bounds on those basis
functions um and if we care about the
principal components on the input we can
track how the data changes through the
network then we can probably prove some
properties about convergence um and i've
i've got some really promising initial
groundwork but uh nothing to share yet
that's fascinating just two things to
pick up on there um just because again
our intuition before was that neural
networks are transforming the data but
they're not are they they're they're
just transforming the basis functions
which give the appearance of
transforming the data let's say if you
were
in the context of a generative model
okay that was the first thing the second
thing is is you were talking you glazed
over it a little bit and i'm not
familiar with this this
model that doesn't do the back prop the
the the forward grip yeah i saw a lot of
conversation around on twitter people
are excited because it's faster right
you don't have to do back prop all the
way through the network um and you know
i read through exactly how they compute
this gradient that was what i was really
interested in like wait that doesn't
make sense how can you have information
about the function you're approximating
travel all the way through the network
if you're not doing backdrop like if
there's no computational connection
between your output and the first layer
what's happening and if you go and look
and then some people can run this
experiment it's fun and i've done it it
looks it looks like it's true
look at the principal components of your
data at in those embeddings
at your first layer you're let's say
you're doing a smaller problem you've
got five major mostly five components
in the next layer let's say you've got
30 or 40 internal nodes in your mlp uh
maybe we'll have a little bit more than
five right you would think because the
non-linear basis functions can increase
the variance of your data so maybe
you'll have six major principal
components and you would hope by the
time you get to the last layer you have
30
unique principal components of data
right you've increased the variance of
your function so if you look at
initialization that's not the case at
all it collapses to one almost always if
you look at the principal component
distribution of your data it collapses
fast wow and what that means is at
initialization time we're losing most of
the data and when you train with that
method that that paper saying look at
the principal components of your data
after you've trained with that method
it's increase the variance is high it
has no connection to your output but
just solely by increasing the diversity
of basis functions that you're
approximating of your space you get a
better final result right i could just
do a linear regressor over the final
embedding of that model and get a better
result than uh than i do with a
regularly initialized network so it's
more of an initialization scheme than it
is an actual training paradigm that's
absolutely fascinating we'd love to have
another conversation with you um yeah
thanks for coming on so much doctor
it's been an absolute pleasure
thank you